o music]
You want-you want
to go put it up?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-You know where it goes?
-You know how to put it up?
-Yes, sir.
[cheerful music]
Carefully.
[laughs]
Trevor thinks he knows
everything,
but he's definitely
still got a lot to learn.
All right.
[music continues]
[grunts]
[air hissing]
[music fades comically]
Ahh! [bleep]
Damn it, almost had it.
[grunts] No!
Ah!
Third try. Ah.
Oh.
[Trevor] Yeah.
Gonna get it.
Gonna...
All right, hold on.
No! Oh... Ohh!
Ahh.
Ah. Might need help.
Might need help.
They think I'm a chump.
Seventh time's the charm,
Trevor.
[breathing heavily]
Michael?
Is there an easier way
to do this?
[Michael]
[Trevor groans loudly]
Why you trying to
put it up there?
[Trevor] 'Cause that's
where it goes.
-Is it?
-[Trevor] Yes.
Did you look at
the other side?
No, I looked at this side
and it was-it was up-up here.
Did you look at
the hose behind you?
It was hanging--
Look, Wes,
it was hanging up there,
all right?
-[Wes] Was it?
-Yes.
Yes, sir.
-Are you sure?
-[Trevor] Positive.
You know there's a hose as
an example right behind you?
[Trevor] Yeah, well, that's not
how it's supposed to go.
[Wes laughs]
[upbeat country music]
[Trevor] Thank you, Dustin,
for helping me.
Ah, it fit!
Got it.
Ohh...
They half-ass things
around here.
I didn't learn that way.
My dad taught me better.
-Did you get it?
-[Trevor] Yep.
Nice.
Now, how are we gonna
get it down?
-[both laugh]
-[Dustin] I know, right?